speaking over Christmas if you guys
start your Christmas shopping yet no
don't remind me bro God I just do you
know what's like at this stage do you
know the question that scares me the
most now it's not it's not me asking
people what they want to Christmas or
going Christmas shopping but when you
get to December and you get about 10
questions from either your friends or
family asking you what do you want for
Christmas for Christmas I'm like I have
no [ __ ] clue
well that's why like my parents took the
easy route since like I was in high
school and they're just like give some
cash buy what you want and like you know
some people will be like oh that's so
like you know heartless like you know
your parents should be thinking about
what to get you've you know like a gift
and you know make it mean something and
I'm like no if anything like I don't
know what I want so like it's better if
I just get the cash and I just buy what
I want you know so it's whatever but
like I but if I do that for other people
then it pisses them off so I'm just like
well [ __ ] what am I supposed to do
because I'm so bad at buying gifts I'm
not even like we've talked about this
before we'd like me and Joey are awful
buying gift but I've realized I'm also
awful at buying gifts for myself for
myself yeah and I'm I'm like the number
one culprit of like when someone asks me
what do I want I'm like I don't [ __ ]
know the problem with me as well is that
like because I either just want like you
know the things that I want the short
list of things that I want in my head
for like the immediate future or like
the far future is always like the two
extremes right so it's like when when
Aki's like oh what do you want for for
like as a gift you know what do you want
me to give you and I'm like ah I'm
debating between a house and a chocolate
bar
it's just like there's nothing in
between that I want it's like if I have
a house that'd be great yeah well give
me a moss ball I kind of I'm craving a
moss ball right now it's like well you
know I know exactly what you mean like
everything you want is not like
Christmas gift it's not it's not in the
budget yes it's it's not it's either too
cheap or way too like or like a life
[ __ ] goal what is this like what is
it like the perfect price of a Christmas
gift in your mind it depends on who
you're giving it to yeah right yeah
because like I kind of tear it out in my
hair yeah
no I tear it out I'm like if it's family
members then okay you know the budget
can be I don't know anywhere between 50
to 200 right like depending on what it
is yeah if it's like a mate right that
you you know you might see every now and
then like then you know you can usually
get some pretty good gifts between like
20 25 dollars yeah so that's that's what
I kind of aim it to do but then there's
that mental game right of like all right
I'm getting my friend something that's
like around 25 what if they give me
something that's way more expensive it's
it's the game of like Christmas chicken
right it's it's like you don't want to
be that guy who just gets like a really
cheap gift and the mate gets like a
really expensive exactly but also you
don't want to be that mate who's a bit
overbearing and I was just like well got
a gift that's way too overly expensive
you're right you know what I mean yeah
it's tough I think that I
in my mind is like let's say I got
urinated all the gift I got you a 200
gift yeah I don't view it as okay I
value God more yeah so yeah maybe I
found a gift that was perfect for Joey
that was 80 bucks right it sucks that I
found the perfect gift for Grant there
was more than I wanted to spend yeah but
I don't think God would ever buy it for
himself and I think this is a great deal
so then it's like okay in my head these
two are like both the perfect gift but
obviously the price is different yeah
yeah so that that's how I kind of look
at it yeah but it's tough it is tough
because then you don't want they might
not view it that way yeah and especially
like if you're on the receiving end of
that as well it's like oh you know oh my
friend could be like oh I got you this
perfect gift it's like a 200 wine
decanter or something yeah oh I got you
a ten dollar stubby holder Merry
Christmas it's like it's like it's like
you know they like that [ __ ] but it's
like well I I think it's all good when
it seems like you didn't put nearly as
much effort as they do oh yeah not
necessarily monetarily but like they're
like oh yeah I put way less thought into
mine yeah and you put way too much
thought into yours one of the things
like oh the thing is there's been points
where I I have received like expensive
gifts right but it's like price isn't
always the thing that's the most
valuable when it comes to like gift
giving sure if there's a gift that's
perfect for someone like it could be
cheaper it could be more expensive I've
like showed out for like a gift that's
more expensive when I think a mate would
like or make a family yeah
yeah really really enjoy this and
everything like that yeah um but also
I've received like cheap gifts that were
just like perfect for me
um that's that I could tell they put
like a lot of thought into yeah
um and I feel like there's that's the
real kind of
that's that's the real trickiness of
like gift giving okay here's a question
I want to ask then do you guys like
getting surprise gifts yeah
I am no surprise no as in like as in
like gifts where it's like you want exp
it's not like a even even if it's like
because like for me ever since I was a
kid whether it's like birthday or
Christmas or anything like that any kind
of Celebration I want to know what I'm
getting
no I hate it I hate it yeah right
sorry you hate not knowing what you're
gonna get yeah I hate receiving surprise
gifts why
it makes me feel okay if there's one
thing that I hate even though even
though I know it's even though I know
most people don't think like this right
yeah this is just a me problem I just
hate feeling like I'm indebted okay
like even if they expected nothing from
Return they were just giving it to me
out of the kindness of their heart and I
know it and I know that and I know the
surprise gift but what occasion okay
even even if it's like no occasion right
like it's like you know uh [ __ ]
friend just came back from somewhere
you're not expecting any kind of gift
but they're like hey I got you something
and I'm like it's cool receiving it
because I'm like oh [ __ ] they care for
me yeah but now I feel bad because now
I'm indebted and I feel like I need to
return the favor
if somebody let me see if they would be
like yeah someone is giving their
surprise gift they're not the type of
person who would then expect something
bad no no
would you want the solution then to be
them not give you a gift what is the
solution to this problem the solution
would be for me to like reprogram my
brain to not okay such a [ __ ] idiot
so what do you prefer having this
anxiety of debt or not receiving the
gift but like uh which one's more
powerful
see that's the tough part right and
that's why I think my solution
personally is for me to be the [ __ ]
to give special gifts no no that's
that's my my solution yeah my solution
if I give people gifts before me I will
never feel indebted that is my solution
I've had this Howie this much of the
same principle I've had this before
because I know Malin feels the same way
and every time I give a maiden a gift
she has the exact same look in her eyes
as I do when I receive a gift yeah I
know I'm like it's like an Asian thing I
don't know what it is
even if it was something that say like
they hand made it because I've received
like handmade gifts from like my friends
before right of like some cool [ __ ] and
I'm like and and you know there's no
monetary value to that because it's not
something they bought right it's
something they've made right so I think
it's more so just the fact that they
went through the effort to think about
me and to get something that they think
I would like yeah that makes me feel bad
yeah it's it's not it's not even it's
not even does that make sense to me it's
not even like anything to do with like
monetary value or anything like that it
could be like a one door thing I'd still
feel bad
okay okay
if you are okay
if for me like
if you need to borrow like five pounds
five dollars off of me yeah does do you
do you remember that [ __ ] and you were
like I am going to pay this back one day
or can it sometimes like oh absolutely I
I make a like a subconscious thing of
like okay uh you know next time you're
paying I'll be like oh yeah by the way
yeah you owe me five bucks but I'll be
like just whatever figure it out I keep
a very rough balance in my head of who
who's oh is what no if I if I borrow
money off anyone I like write that [ __ ]
down on my phone I'm like I owe this
person this much money yeah it's it's
just like I'm a [ __ ] Lannister the
debt is being paid whether they like it
or not I find the people are way more
forgetful when it's like oh hey I'll get
you a coffee and then you don't think
like oh he spent five bucks like he got
me a coffee and then it's very easy to
forget that someone got you a coffee
even though that's the exact same
monetary value Plus work of bringing it
to you yeah yeah so like that that's
harder to keep track of right yeah then
that's normally how what you you have
like the the
um the very casual balance sheet between
you and your friend that's in your head
it's like okay he bought me five coffees
I am three drinks or something you know
right yeah so you kind of like pay it
back right that's how I'm more so like
because when do I actually need to
borrow cash I don't it's like can you
get this drink yeah yeah yeah that's
more so what my life comes down when
have you when's the last time you ever
asked for cash
I mean like a very long time I did like
a week ago yeah but I paid it back like
immediately yeah yeah but that that's me
as well when that's like 500 bucks
though it's different
it's not it's not it's not quite though
boy can you you've got a spare tire I
have the same energy of like can I have
the 500 bucks and I'll give it you back
oh my God
I don't know where this came from it
doesn't matter if it's like a surprise
gift or even if it's just like a casual
favor or something if I if I feel like
oh someone a favor that like that that
that keeps me up at night because I'm
just like when I'm when is this when am
I gonna feel like okay I'm 100 comes
down to uh viewer money though I'm
pretty sure and how you how you valued
because you know time equals money yes
we I think you don't want someone's time
energy or like kind of money and how you
viewed it and how you've been brought up
viewing it I think it definitely ties
into that like if you look back at how
you were taught about money it's
probably the same kind of mindset as
like um now with the gift giving of like
right if somebody gives you something
you give it back yes if somebody I mean
that is like super ingrained into
Japanese okay I don't think it's money I
just what was that was that of a
distilled into you where money if
someone lends you money or you work you
have to work for your money you have to
do I think it all comes down to that
where you put a certain value on time
and money in your head because you're
because you're raised to and you value
that and so I think that that carries on
in in odd ways and odd Quotes no I I I I
I don't think so because to me I'm I'm
like trying to like psychoanalyze myself
right now I never want to feel like
I'm not valuing our friendship or our
relationship as much as they value I I
never want them to feel like I don't
value our friendship or our relationship
as much as I do so whenever someone goes
out of their way to do something nice
for me I'm like that that's I you know
I'm [ __ ] touched because I'm like
[ __ ] but yeah but then I guess that that
means you're then you're saying that the
value of the friendship or what value
you bring to it is is you can Define it
with objects or monetary like value
you're saying if you give me a gift and
I don't give you one back I didn't value
the friendship as much as you whereas I
disagree because a lot of people can get
way more fulfilling things out of a
friendship like you might have like
let's say you know you've helped me out
way more than you realize and then I
give you a gift in my head that's not me
saying hey now you owe me one it's like
no no I know that a lot yeah but that's
what I'm saying like that means you're
viewing it the way you're subconsciously
looking at it is like okay there is this
has value and this is how the Friendship
works I think I think I think is tied to
the whole that might be a little bit of
that but I think in my head there's more
so the matter of like I would rather you
spend that money and time on yourself or
other people other than me yeah because
right you guys said you feel bad
I feel bad because I in my head I'm like
that could be a gift or a money span or
time spent finding that gift or whatever
or time spent making the money to buy
that gift that you could use on yourself
or other people in your life oh sure
appreciation yeah yeah and that's why
and that's why like that's that's what I
mean by I feel bad because it's like I
already for the most time I already
value the relationship that I have with
this person just them being a maid and
then you know [ __ ] with me right and
it's like
you know like you know them like you
know [ __ ] vibing with me right it's
like just the fact that you're my friend
is like more than enough for me right so
it's like I would rather as a friend I
would rather you I mean I appreciate
getting the gift no matter how much it
costs right no matter how quick or long
it took to get that gift but in my head
I'm like I already appreciate you enough
as a friend and as a friend I would
rather see you use that time and money
on other people than me yeah because I
don't need it so you know for the most
part yeah yeah I agree with that
um I think
so going back to like I think a lot of
everyone has a different thing that they
really put a lot of weight on you know I
think that like as I've got older uh and
had to balance more friendships and seen
how they work in more adult situations
I'm like okay some people when they like
really appreciate a friendship they'll
go out there and make gifts some people
will go out of their way to arrange a
really cool hangout and they'll do
everything right yeah some people really
value maybe how quickly you text back or
how quickly you stay in touch right yeah
it's like everyone has like value that
they assign to certain things yeah and
it's just about being an adult is trying
to figure out hey this friend he really
likes it when I reply to text quickly or
this friend really appreciates it when I
give them a gift that you know they
didn't think about or this friend really
appreciates it when I take them out for
a good time and so I think it's it's
just like you're probably in a different
category where you value something else
more in a friendship than a gift yes and
to you a gift seems like oh [ __ ] I gotta
I have to give this back to show that I
appreciate you where it's like no I can
I would normally show it in my own way
which might be I'll hang out with you
and chat with you for hours and yeah
you're the first person I'd want to go
to for this type of topic you know what
I mean yeah it's weird it's cheesy but
it's like to me it's like your presence
is a gift me too me right it's like it's
like just the fact that you're there and
you're my friend I agree more than it is
it's cheesy but I feel the exact same
way when I'm just like [ __ ] I've just
just just being around me is enough of
them you're my friend is like all that I
could ask for I'm sure you've probably
met that type of person who's always
buying gifts even though like they're
broke yeah
and like that's just like I think that's
just like a personality trait where yeah
they really value being able to
physically show that they they enjoy the
friendship or whatever it is yeah that's
how in their head it's like fulfilling
to kind of give back like physically
with like an item by the way is there
any friends of ours watching this
I just want to say if you give me a gift
I'm not gonna be like get the [ __ ] out
of here right like I'll take it but like
I'll take it okay
you don't have to here's the thing no no
no we're all pretty we all do pretty
pretty good money-wise yes it becomes
way [ __ ] harder to buy gifts to
people who can buy things yes this has
been a me issue no matter what I'm
trying to say that
let's say I have all the money in the
world how do I buy you a gift card well
I know if you want something you're just
gonna buy it because you can afford it
but that's why that's why I'm not going
up to [ __ ] stupid money yeah but
that's why again I value just like you
being there and when I need you or you
know when you want to hang out and stuff
like that I I value that kind of
relationship in a friendship so much
more than I ever have in my life yeah